[Music]
don't look at your fantasy updates
you're Los you're going to lose this
week you're going to lose okay sorry go
ahead you're losing it doesn't matter I
know you're going to have to shave your
eyebrows just accept it what's the loss
for your punishment I think it's uh get
ready with me you have to post one on
Tik Tok full makeup that's pretty CR and
you have to tell you you have to tell
like a a bad story the whole time right
and do your face full of makeup like you
have to take it seriously beat full you
can't be laughing you have to Full Beat
Your Face Off no irony no yeah that's I
think that would be pretty tough it
ain't even like the guy who was like
rapping the goofy song no cuz he's
clearly like [__] around literally
reading off something yeah you have to
be like get ready with me for dinner
with my wife you know so we're going to
this restaurant today I've always wanted
to try this pasta V Jewel and you know
but if you really own it then it may
just Escape people it would definitely
be out of character for me to put a full
face of makeup on but if you just own it
then it like goes on long enough where
people
go I like this yeah yeah yeah they
become supportive yeah so you're saying
like do it for like 10 minutes mhm yeah
you have to make it really long yeah and
like practice beforehand so the makeup
is like it's like a sleigh
yeah then then it's hysterical if at the
end you just have like a perfect that
would be sick actually and you're just
like all right all right that's it kind
of nice yeah all right everyone see you
next time bye yeah five million likes
yeah should we drink some more of this
[__] no man you jonesen we got to do
something put it in your
coffee slam it now oh that's going to be
so no this is what Phils does is you
ever had Phils yeah yeah that's their
dirty little secret it's o oil what do
you mean they put oil and I'm pretty
sure they put heavy whipping cream also
in their coffee that's why it's so
[__] sweet and creamy no then
Starbucks did it but they got like
everyone tried it and they were like
what the [__] this sucks have you tried
this one no it's not good I had
Starbucks this morning you little
bastard I know I'm a little [__] you
switch sides truly you I had a matcha
too oh you matcha matcha a matcha no
yeah this is the small mind part of the
mod modcast nowcast what's I have no
word dude we've said so many words this
week I don't have any good opinions left
yeah I actually never had any but um
yeah I'm burn I'm burnt the [__] out
start dude start anime what I think
you'll like anime you know why I well I
want to do um do do aack on Titan here's
why okay fine the amount of drama that
you would you would get in a a whole
film that for you is like [__] I
don't it's like Fast and Furious no but
that was too much for
me no but what I'm saying is you'll get
it in 20 minutes yeah and if you skip
the intro and credits I think an average
the attack on Titan episode is 17
minutes long okay and you'll get a movie
like 5,000 Seasons there's only five
okay
thousand well there's five for the first
chapter and then there's 16 chapters in
the first like part of the three-part
book that's I feel like anime is always
like that the show's been on for 35
years yeah no no this one is um I see
how they can get so many episodes out
you can Crush three in an hour yeah okay
yeah okay maybe I'll try it what about
side piece or no not side Piece One
Piece One Piece side
piece what about that woman's side piece
yeah I think it's called side chick I I
watched three minutes of the live action
and I don't like this premise what is it
it's like Pirates and what's the uh live
action on Netflix oh by the way the SAG
strike is over the so strike hell yeah
so oh it's over so big up we did it we
did it fastex Barbie Oppenheimer say it
all yes I can say whatever I want
now I watched The Godfather did I tell
you that uh no no did I not I started it
didn't finish it that's actually your
anime just 15minute intervals yeah yeah
no it was good but you know wasn't good
enough sorry you wanted to do
relationship advice well I mean you
thought the Godfather was bad I didn't
think it was bad but I just let's do a
relationship okay so tell me about what
was the anime you thought the Godfather
was bad no see when they jizz it's like
130 got it little here I 26 male you
thought the Godfather was bad
did you actually no one piece is great
did you you actually did not like The
Godfather no I didn't not like it it's
just old you know it's too old but no
it's also very long and uh some of it's
[__] boring yeah but I mean it's like
the you know it's like the most highly
rated movie of all time yeah so I should
watch the whole thing yeah and I did
like some of it but not all of it I
don't
know i 26 M what opinion on
it I've never seen it have you not no
I've actually been intending to watch it
for like
years yeah that's what I mean it's like
it's tough to watch cuz it's so old do
you even like film
making no it's tedious and boring JK all
right let's let's do this redit post
before we go I 26 male found her 28
female Tik Tok after we went on a date
this is honestly not something I
expected to post about but here's the
thing I have known this woman for a
while since we are in the same friend
groups she's a nice person attractive
and honestly I've always enjoyed my
talks with her a few weeks ago I asked
her out on a date I figured if she says
no it's fine but she actually
agreed we went on a date this past
Saturday and honestly I thought it was
awesome we went out for dinner had
drinks spent the rest of the night
talking and we even took a walk on a
walking bridge over the Town's Lake
before she pegged me at
home I dropped her off and was a no that
doesn't say that I dropped her off and
was elated I absolutely loveed the night
okay sounds like a great
date however that night when I was
scrolling through Tik Tok on my bed a
post from her I didn't follow her nor
she had a Tick's Australian nor I didn't
follow nor know she had a Tik Tok
appeared
on appeared on my 4 You page my for you
page as it's commonly called now just
pause you can you see how you know this
person watches anime why just like the
read this in the anime
voice you do
it however that night when I was
scrolling through Tik Tok on my bed a
post from her I didn't mean to see cuz I
don't follow her I didn't even know she
had a Tik Tok anyway anyway it appeared
on my foru page essentially she said in
the post getting ready for a date that I
don't really want to go to
what that was like a bucket of ice water
being thrown on my head I was so
freaking happy I just found out she
didn't want to go on a date with me I
mean don't get me wrong I'm not saying
she has to want it but please let me
know if that's the
case I think this is fine
honestly I think it's the modern era
it's the modern era yeah but like and
maybe she I mean it's not clear why she
didn't want to go on the date like if
she was like yeah this guy's just really
[__] ugly yeah then that would have
been that that would have sucked you
know but if she was like I just don't
want to go out tonight and they go have
a great times like what's what's the
problem with that yeah and people have
apprehensions at all different parts of
life man maybe there was something else
going on in her life that she was
projecting on to you that was your
opportunity to show her that you were
different you're spitting that you're
not like the others yeah pych she just
did she just no
showed and then don't you dare throw
anything it's my [__] birthday dude
don't throw anything what if I just
reached over and punched
you with the liquid oh you got me
again yeah man a [__] oh that's good
that was a good one that was a good one
[__] you that was a good
one if you're listening on audio you
missed the
joke uh no it was Ryan gestured throwing
a paper
towel